let's get to those fires in California
where powerful new winds could bring
more devastation to parts of the state
already ravaged by wildfires crews
battling the massive Kincaid fire in
Northern California's wine country fear
the wind could fan the flames it has
burned an area more than twice the size
of San Francisco and destroyed nearly 60
homes Jonathan Vigliotti is in Helzberg
California and Jonathan good morning so
many people there are living without
power yeah that's correct good morning
to you Tony even with the power cut off
I want to show you what some homes face
the flames ripping through this one and
many others this is the outside of it
through there you could see what we
believe was the living room about
500,000 people at this hour are still in
the dark many more evacuated don't even
know the fate of their homes as this
state faces a climate crisis PG&E says
their only option here has been to turn
off this power but now the state is
investigating the utilities strategy and
the threat it poses to the people caught
in the middle of it California's largest
utility PG&E now says two fires that
broke out Sunday less than 20 miles
northeast of San Francisco in Lafayette
including one that destroyed this Tennis
Club may have been caused by its own
electrical malfunctions
despite cutting power to more than two
and a half million people the
electricity was not turned off in the
area because it wasn't designated as
high risk if we did go into a mode where
we wanted to prevent everything from
happening then we'd have to shut the
whole system down and that's just not
acceptable the utility also says it
failed to notify 23,000 customers
including 500 with medical conditions
before shutting off their power we're
gonna investigate all of this and we're
gonna make determination as culpability
six days after the Kinkaid fire first
ignited firefighters are scrambling to
put out hotspots in hopes of getting an
upper hand before wind gusts reaching as
high as 50 miles an hour
kick up again the wind will carry
burning materials sometimes miles ahead
of the fire so we're having to go
and one by one deal with those and
mitigate those dangers as they pop up
which is always a difficulty being
dynamic and not just a set fire line in
Southern California where high winds
fueled the Getty fire in the early
morning hours Monday authorities are
manning their fire lines with additional
personnel their concern predicted gusts
of up to 80 miles an hour I've asked my
command staff to do everything possible
to assure that the line is cold is as
cold as possible before those winds kick
up and with the wind expected to pick up
later today PG&E is already warning they
could conduct their third power cut in
less than one week Gail that means
nearly 4 million people could be in the
dark hey Jonathan those pictures are
unbelievable we look at you standing
there in the quiet and the darkness and
you see the flames do you think that
people are fighting the fires what they
have to breathe and the smoke and the
heat it's it's terrifying really to
watch it thank you very much